israel's most politically diverse
coalition government lasted just a year
parties including the hard right
liberals and for the first time
palestinian israelis had come together
with one aim to end benjamin netanyahu's
consecutive years as prime minister
netanyahu is currently on trial for
corruption with his far-right and
ultra-orthodox allies he engineered the
failure to renew a measure that allows
jewish settlers in the occupied west
bank to live under israeli law
now netanyahu has promised to win a
sixth term in office to bibi or not to
bb that has been the only question for
four elections it will be the only uh
issue for a fifth i i'm sorry if it
makes israelis look shallow uh that they
don't deal with the peace process
security iran matters of religion and
state none of those issues came up in
the first four elections so i don't
expect the fifth to be any different
the new caretaker prime minister is a
centrist yaya lapid this former
television celebrity replaces naftali
bennett
lapid has cast netanyahu's potential
return to office as a national threat
he's been running a very good campaign
for the last you know eight or ten years
which is he's not going to go with
netanyahu he's a replacement with
netanyahu he didn't fall into that trap
and netanyahu all the time is running
the negative campaign of
we're going to have a disaster if you're
lapidus prime minister well surprise
he's the prime minister he will be the
prime minister in a few days and
therefore as long as the sky doesn't
fall in those four months then people
will be able to expect yar lapid is a
reasonable prime minister
even with a centrist caretaker prime
minister there's not likely to be any
progress in talks with the palestinians
behind lapeed there is still bennett
who's opposed to any idea of a
palestinian state
netanyahu's likud party leads the polls
but it wouldn't win enough seats to form
a governing majority the next election
could end up being the first in a series
as israel heads into another period of
political instability
bernard smith al-jazeera west jerusalem